i'm bob fine
uh let me
let me start here so
this is me uh in
my studio in charleston south carolina
so i have uh i've i had a
30 plus year career on wall street
as a municipal finance banker doing a
lot of quantitative
analytical stuff uh it was
the last 12 years using mathematica to
do
cash flow default analysis and
operations over bloomberg data sets
but we uh i i i i
typically don't like to use the work but
the word but i'm retired so
at at the end of 2018 my wife and i sold
our
house in westchester county i i was
commuting into grand central for
uh about 32 or 33 years
and we moved to seabrook island which is
one of the barrier islands just uh just
south of charleston
and uh since
the march of 2019
i've been i've got my interest in
digital photography kind of morphed
into using mathematics create digital or
computational art so you can see i'm
kind of very proudly standing next to
one of my works which is a kind of a
golden sphere which
is on canvas and i had printed i have a
big 44 inch wide
epson p9000 printer in my studio
and uh that what you're looking at is
uh i again can i i wrapped
the canvas myself around the frame uh
and uh you know it's uh it's it's
it it's very interesting and uh
no offense to uh to any golfers that are
listening
i don't play golf so this is uh
this endeavor kind of keeps me focused
and uh
and uh it's very challenging and i love
to do it each day
so again my my background is again on
wall street
let me i've got a statement to kind of
orient my uh my interest as an artist
and then i'll i'll talk about the
different kinds of rendering
i've been focused on geometric rendering
which
once you see the images you'll know
exactly kind of what these
what this means space colonization
fractal models and perspective
so
it's my background which i've learned
gone over
so this is important as an artist i play
with mathematical algorithms
by configuring them in ways that
instruct
pixels to uh to form
images on a computer screen or digital
printer that appear
lifelike and organic or at a minimum
interesting like most artists i think
about color
shape form dimension and perspective
unlike most artists i think about how to
express these attributes as a set of
mathematical instructions
that map the position of pixels
onto the 2d cartesian space and assign
each pixel varying combinations of red
green
and blue color values expressed as real
numbers between zero
and one so i know that to any normal
audience or
or or non-technical or non-quantitative
audience that
they would be asleep by now but i know
that you
you guys all kind of understand exactly
what i just said
uh i i i want to make a a a
i think a point here because i've been
in putting this together putting the
presentation together i've been thinking
about the issue of
well am i you know i ideally i'm
i'm starting at the simple and and
through these algorithms
the algorithms are generating something
very complex but it's a little more
subtle than that because
it's not just simple algorithms as
you'll see as i go through the
presentation
uh there's still
there's a lot i need there's a lot that
needs to happen as a lot of you need to
think through in terms of kind of uh in
terms of managing and
and getting getting precise images
the second part of this so i work within
a
this is important i work within a small
subset of computer graphics which of
course is huge
so i don't do animation i don't do
photographic real photo realistic
rendering
i don't do grain game creation i don't
do
ai so my my work is static
i prefer i deliver a deliverable that's
either a high resolution
tiff or png file or a print on fine art
paper or canvas that i produce
as i said before using a high-end
inkjet printer so this to succeed my
work needs to remain simple yet have a
stylistic component that makes the image
relatable to the viewer
and and yeah and and
on a larger level i i've kind of set out
an
ambitious goal for myself which is to
is is is to take these kind of
computational techniques
and and and and and to explore
and see to what extent i can create what
what in the in in the real world is
considered fine art
something that people would buy at a
gallery
to hang on their living room walls or
alternatively as as an investment
i know that's quite ambitious and uh i'm
kind of
at the uh kind of beginnings of that
uh the pandemic has has actually
allowed me to uh uh i haven't been into
my studio in charleston for for about
six or seven months
just not taking any chances and but as a
result i've been here
at my computer uh just
working on the uh on programming
techniques
i want to and as i said
strongly assert the fact that i make no
attempt to express any part of my inner
being in my work
i i you know i i read all the statements
that
that talk about that and i mean
my initial reaction is to say you know
what does this even mean
so i just i i approach my work pearl
purely in the spirit of play and
discovery and a very satisfied merely to
see form and coherence appear
and i would add here that i think the
the role of an
artist is not to express themselves but
to understand
and control their work so uh
in terms of how understand how how the
viewers are going to react to their work
you know not how they're expressing
themselves directly in their work
so uh as an overview to the kind of
rest of what i'm going to talk about i
uh you know for the first six months i
i focused on rendering uh geometric
solids
that i expressed algorithmically i'll
show you and then
and then since then and i i
the the key here is that i realized that
well
that what i was doing geometrically
wasn't going to have any interest to the
35 or so uh at art galleries
uh in charleston so i i i
was i started thinking about kind of
more organic renderings
and shapes so let me go into the
geometric rendering
and i i won't spend a lot of time
getting into the detail here but
i i will say that this stuff is easy and
that you know here's a parametric
equation
of a sphere where your uh
uh generating the x y and z values
uh a across uh
parameters of zero to pi and and minus
pi over two to
pi over two and this is the actual
mathematic mathematica function
uh using table and then this is the
actual
the function that that renders the image
you can see
where i i first create a canvas where
all the pixels are
black zero zero zero and then i map the
coordinates
that uh that i generated above
uh which also have a color value each
pixel head now has a
color value assigned to it of 1 1 1
which is white
and then map it over the matrix and then
uh use the image function and the export
function
to to render it and so here we have
an example of a mobius strip
where i had a parametric equation of uh
a mobius strip
and and and and rendered it and now the
frame here
is is is uh is is artificial like
created in a photoshop but
but the rendering itself is it looks
very much like the print wood because uh
if familiar if you're not familiar with
inkjet printing they
they're essentially two there's a matte
black ink and a photo black ink
i i printed these out with matte black
ink which is
very black in other words it reflects
very little light
so these are actually stunning
you know uh very elegant
and uh i'll show you uh so here's a
sphere
and and and the and the uh
the uh uh detail in the and the
subtle luminosity here is just
incredible and this
and this all shows up you know given the
quality of the
printer this this subtlety all shows up
uh this is a sphere 2 with a
slightly different lighting
this is a cloud variation on a klein
bottle
this is a just a simple cylinder
now so i've had people through my studio
it's it's in an opera it's part of a
not-for-profit organization in
charleston it's called redux
and they have open houses and they have
auctions so i've had people through my
studio
where i've had all these up on the wall
looks like a little gallery in itself
and you know the older more kind of
state established
people are kind of don't have no idea
what to make of it but but but there's a
class of millennials
younger who who are just kind of just
can't stop staring at this stuff
and uh unfortunately though they're
still at a stage in their career where
they're not art buyers so
i again it's kind of a transition
as i you know more as a challenge as
much as anything else
you know how do i kind of like attract a
more
kind of stayed uh uh uh clientele
but but my wife had kind of uh urged me
to kind of start to work with color
so here's some here's a sphere that's
very interesting kind of very delicate
uh striations in in the uh
in the rendering
another one kind of very bright red
sphere
and and the other thing with these with
these trigonomic equations
there may you know when i say they're
easy i mean all this lighting effect
really comes from the math it comes from
god
uh i'm not doing anything here except
except creating this a gradient here
and and so and and and and and taking
the
the the color values for each pixel and
wrapping them with a
with a cosine statement which creates
this uh
this sinusoidal effect between dark and
light
this is interesting this is a a series
of
archimedes spirals kind of looking
head-on i don't know if you can see it
on your screen but it's
that there's nothing these are well that
it's rendered in
3d and then projected into 2d uh
it looks almost 3d here because it's
just so hard
for the for the eye to focus on the uh
on
on on this on the swirl in front and the
swirls in the back
and i took the same data set and just
rotated it
to get this perspective which i think is
interesting
so
the organic world is something called a
space colonization
algorithm which has nothing to do with
colonizing outer space
but it's about creating uh a point cloud
and then creating branches to reach out
to the
the the points in the point cloud are
called leaves
and you can see that you you create a a
a
a set of the distance
you you you you assume a minimum
distance and then you find all the
branches and leaves that were in
are within that min minimize distance
and you create an average
vector off of your last branch and
and and and run and and and
uh increase it by a length that's
imported
and then that grows to trees and as the
tree grows the
the leaves are deleted so
this is uh kind of a progression in
terms of developing this algorithm
so here's a simple simple progression
another simple one and it while i'm
doing this
i'm kind of it becomes a very
complicated algorithm
and there's uh and there's a a function
an algorithm
uh it's called a breslin ham algorithm
that actually draws the lines
and that's the thickness to the lines
and again so now i'm doing now i'm
rendering this with with 3d vectors
projected to the 2d plane and you can
see there's some really interesting kind
of lighting effects here
and again here here's kind of simple in
3d
and a little more complex and these
things were taking
taking a long time to run and so what i
do now is
just to kind of as a matter of course
anything any function
any matrix multiplication where i'm also
playing big matrices
and the numbers of the numbers of pixels
that are running through this
can be easily 60 you know 16 15 million
20 million
so i compile them and that the compiling
kind of
increases the speed uh 15 to 20 fold is
kind of incredible
so what had been taking like hours to
run i can run in like 20 minutes
so here's another one becoming more
complex
another one and this one is
i like a lot and i played with the color
here
so now i've got trees and so with the
context is i'm thinking
how do i build a scene so now i've got
trees so any
now i need to work on this on the sky
structure
so what there's something sorry
well okay so i get this is more
uh this is more organic forms i'm not
quite at the
at the uh structure of this of the sky
these are iterated function systems the
most famous iterative function system is
the bar
barnsley fern and the these are
recursive systems
and you can see in in this barnsley fern
that the the
the each of the parts is a copy of the
whole
and and there's a lot of literature
there's a lot of literature out there
kind of
there are a lot of examples kind of
rendered using mathematica for these
functions
and so as i'm kind of running short let
me just show you a few
so you can see even that the stems
are just compressed versions of of of
of the hole and these are essentially
what's happening is these are
four refine a fine transformations
which involve a scaling a rotation and a
translation
to get to get these images and it's it's
based on a
on a on a set of coefficients and the
coefficients have to be
if you can adjust your coefficients you
can get these very
organic looking shapes and you can
actually solve for the coefficients by
by by creating your own uh drawing and
finding the points
and then and then including the points
as a system of solving for a system of
linear equations that were to solve for
the points that will give you the
coefficients
and so this is this i like a lot is very
painly
it's very organic pain really in the
sense that these
kind of look like brush strokes
and here's another one that's again very
painly that i like a lot
so now we're exploring now i'm exploring
starting to explore
cloud structures using structured noise
and there's a function in in in
mathematica called fractional browning
motion it's a process
which you wrap with random function to
get a set of
points and it would solve you know for
for an x y an an x array and a y array
and those become my coordinates
and and there's a and the the famous
kind of noise that is pulling noise uh
you can find an example of that under uh
neat examples in the compile function
another documentation i'll come back to
that
but so here's fractional browning
brownian motion that
creates very interesting kind of cloud
formations
and when you
take your color gradient
and map it from white to the color of
your background
you kind of actually you know it becomes
kind of pretty
pretty pretty amazing to see these
things appear
to see these cloud structures appear so
i'm at 120.
uh and then i started being concerned
with uh
with perspective and so i've got a a a
simple
uh pinhole camera engine and uh
and john mcgee and the consulting group
can help me put this together
and so what this does is i can i can
take the vertices
represented by this grid and put them
through the engine
and now i've got pre now i've got a
perspective view of that grid
and this is critical in developing
terrain
and so that this is my one of my tree
algorithms that i put through the grid
and it's kind of very striking
i think and that you're kind of now at
the bottom of the tree
looking up at it and into the sky
this is raw pearl and noise
and what you and so this is expressed as
luminosity but you'll convert the
luminosity to a height map
and then you can
you can then ex uh see this is
these are the the points along with an
x coordinate and a z coordinate uh
uh put through the uh put through the uh
perspective engine and you can see that
th
this this is very evocative of a
computer game
terrain this is something i'm
kind of fooling around with to kind of
get these to get a
higher frequency in the function to
create this kind of
grass-like turf which i think is
interesting
and here i've kind of focus using it
using the pinhole camera really focused
in and this is interesting to me
because it's evocative quite a vocative
of the mosh grass and the colors
that uh that are i can see just
just actually out outside my door
and here i've kind of put it all
together so i've got my clouds
i've got my tree and i've got my terrain
i'm not
particularly yeah i mean the terrain it
clearly is a work in progress
but i mashed these together and i and i
you know it's
it's kind of very interesting
let me
to so the last thing uh
are l systems and they're like iterative
function systems
and there's a whole lot on l systems in
michael trott's mathematica guidebook
for graphics
it uses an axiom and a replacement rule
and essentially
recursively what's happening is you that
every time kind of you have an f
it's any f is replaced by this set of
characters and the f
essentially this is like a turtle
graphic so
f is means you move forward uh the
the brackets are are are uh push and pop
uh uh commands like you would find
in uh in in uh in python
you know he has a very interesting way
of
working those in because mathematica
doesn't have directly push and pop but
the plus means
rote rotate rotate at a at a
at an angle that's input and then move
forward
and then minuses rotate the other way
and so
what these do is pre create these
incredibly kind of elegant and delicate
little
kind of uh plants and grasses
again if you get the right kind of axiom
and so what i've i'm doing now is saying
all right i've got this
and i want to use this kind of to to
to to reflect in my terrain so
i just i use a translation function and
an
and a set of uh random integers
to kind of move uh multiply these around
and uh and so this is
this is just the first projection but
then i run it through the projection
image uh
engine and i get something like this
which i think again is very interesting
it still needs a lot of work and there's
one kind of
interesting complication that i i think
i've worked through
and that when you when you put this
through the uh
uh perspective engine the the
the what where the vertices kind of in
the foreground get stretched out
so these all have to be re-rendered
through the line function
uh aft after the rendering but again
that's
i that's why i come back to say yes
it's it's easy to say yeah i'm taking
some very simple assumptions and and
generating some
you know complex images or generating a
lot of complexity
but uh there are a lot of kind of
details
uh uh that you kind of
that you have to deal with uh to get
this thing
to to render an image that uh you know
again
people will find engaging so
i i'm going to stop the presentation
because it's 126.
and just quickly
look at the chat to see if there are
any questions and hopefully i can find
this
are there any questions i don't see any
let me refresh
oh hi okay so what do i
three minutes okay people are saying hi
yeah this is really
okay enjoying a lot
my screen size is i don't i don't know
it's it's kind of wide aspect ratio
the aspect ratio is is 9 by 16. i think
it's about 30
34 inches across
the background
i'm curious
okay this is from james codd this is an
important question uh
compute bro breslin ham yourself or
instead of using the underlying graphic
system so
uh i started out
kind of not wanting to depend on the
graphic system
i i wanted to uh kind of uh
kind of do everything myself and so i
i you know there are examples of the
bresenham algorithm
online and i actually found an ex a
one-line example of breslin ham
using the array function in in in
in in a very kind of interesting way in
mathematica
and so i'm using that but then i had i
had to build out
uh i had to add on the uh
the ability to uh create thickness
particularly when i was doing the space
colonization
space colonization algorithm and what
i'm doing there is so
you can run 20 25 iterations of the
space colonization algorithm to
clear out your tree so i i i track
i i track that metric and then
and reverse it so that so that the first
branches
so that the first branches drawn have
that
are rendered with that thickness and
then that later branches are
are are are rendered with with the
smaller thickness so
i ideally i'd you know i'd like to
rely more on the the mathematica
graphics and i'm i'm starting to do that
the uh the uh some of the l system
images i've
i've rendered kind of using the line
system
so uh dan hooper have you considered
using measurements of the natural world
to your
form your art methods uh
that's very interesting because i
haven't quite done that but i'm kind of
i under certainly understand work
through just a little bit of
uh uh you know taking photo taking
photographs of plants that look somewhat
fractal-like
and and actually measuring them and saw
the idea would be to
to solve for the color set it up as a
system of linear equations and then
solve for the coefficients but i'm kind
of headed in that
directions uh direction
one of my favorite pieces i mean i
i love the geometric pieces i mean as i
said they're
they draw themselves and they're from
god
i i you know they're very elegant
but again i just love the i love the
fractals too
uh the moire patterns from uh
from uh from james cobb uh
i've i mean you can see those in my
geometric uh
in in in my geometric pieces and again
they
they just draw themselves in there
they're uh they're fascinating
so it's it's 1 30 now oh let's see
it's
it's strange attractors right that's
part of uh
chaos theory that's all kind of tied
into the fractals and
and the uh and so yeah i've i've looked
at that you know i
i looked at that at those some of those
patterns and i just wasn't kind of they
didn't
initially kind of knock my socks off so
again i've been focusing more on on
the the organic part there's a website
called uh algorithmic botany which you
should check out algorithmic botany.com
which
has more information that you'd ever
ever need for for
all of this stuff so
well thank you uh
for for listening and i hope you all
enjoyed it
let me let me say this in closing uh
i'm i'm here's my contact information
please reach out to me if you have any
questions
any ideas on collaboration any ideas on
kind of how to with a big challenge is
to kind of
disseminate this out into the world i
mean i think
uh you know to i'm 20 or 30 years from
now
uh it's it's going to be uh one of the
mainstays of modern art
uh so in that sense ahead of my time
uh you know i don't know if i have 20
or 30 years kind of left but and
and again anything here is if you it's
for sale so if you're interested in it
uh
you know email me we can we can talk on
the phone and
and on instagram i'm uh i'm at fine
robert
so again thank you for uh for paying
attention
and and listening
hey dan are you there yes sir
would you like me to close the meeting
what do you think
if you are finished you are welcome to
do so
uh i can wait
a few more minutes to see if any sean
in the chat had another question for you
oh i see if you consider using geometric
group
theory in your art
the answer is no i'm not sure what it is
but if
if you i appreciate you know you're
reaching out to me
and uh through the through uh
through my email and i i'd love to uh
to uh talk to you and get get a little
more information on that
you